はい これで本当に講演はここから始まるんです
あれは前書きです 長すぎですけど
で カンマダアヤダという言葉
たったそれだけの言葉覚えておきましょう
意味は生命は業を相続していると
たったこれだけで職業論を喋ってみます
業を増殖している生命は
今日の話はたったこれだけなんです
それわかっているならば
別に話ここで終了できますけど
はい 業って何やと 善悪行為とその結果をまとめて業というんですね
行為と結果をまとめて呼んでいます
善行為も悪行為も全部
それから善果も悪果も全部まとめて業と呼ぶんですよ
それを覚えておいてください
ごちゃ混ぜになっているみたいですね
業と言った途端 悪いものだと勘違いするんです
ではないんです 悪いものもいいものも全部業という専門用語なんです
生まれる時 結果としての業を相続するんです
どんな生命も 犬も猫も誰でも鳥も
生まれる時は何か相続して
持ってくるんです 皆さんはあちこち旅に出るときはね
やっぱりクレジットカードとかね
あるいは財布にお金をいくら入れてとかね
行くでしょうに そんなようなもんですよ
だからまあ 日本ではほとんど現金持っていく習慣ですけど
で だからいくらか財布に現金入れて
で じゃあ京都にでも行ってみようかなとか行くんでしょうに
そこで京都で何しようか
全てあの財布で決めちゃいますね
で クレジット アメリカとかまあいう西洋ではもうもうお金持って行きませんし
みんなクレジットカードですけどね
これが日本人にその習慣をつけちゃうと危ない危険
だって頭はじめから悪いでしょうに
収入に合わせて生活しないでしょ
アメリカにもその問題が起きたんですよ
もう誰しない連中がね
で クレジットカードで買うわ買うわ
それからもう金がない
それでお金なんとかして戻してもらおうというと
全体的にみんなやっちゃってるんだから
会社まで倒産する 銀行まで倒産する
そんなもうもうもうむちゃくちゃアホな人間でね
この地球は困るんですよ
だからまあ民主主義でもなんでもなく
檻に入れて管理した方がいいんですよ
そこまで頭が悪いんだったら危ないんで
この自由な世界は 自由な世界では自分で自分の管理をしなくちゃいけないんですよ
自由はとてもありがたいことですが
自分で責任を持つということもあります
クレジットカードで何でも買えるんだからといって買うんじゃないんです
日本のコマーシャルの場合は
一番たくさんのコマーシャルなんですかね
あのローンのコマーシャルでしょ
またローンのコマーシャルのこの道徳観が
もう腹が立ちますけど
あの まあポケットに穴があったらいくらでも入れても落ちますから気をつけましょうとか
だから計画的にローンしましょうと
何言ってるんですかね
だから道徳かぶり負けして非道徳でしょうに
ローンするんじゃないんですよ
まあ明日明後日来週 あの収入は入りますけど
用事が際を出ましたならば
まあそこでちょこっと借りるという程度だったらいいんですよ
だから私はすごく偏見でローンする人っていうのは信頼信頼できないんだと
と思っているんです それよりも私はもっとひどいことというのは
頭が最低やと思う 無知だと
お釈迦様おっしゃるのは
世の中で危険というものがあるならば
すべて無知な人が作るんだと
アングットルニカイにアングットルニカイ始めるのはこういう
そのセクションからです
無知所というセクションがありまして
むちゃくちゃ言われているんです
いかに無知が悪いかと
だから無知の反対は理性なんですよ
そういうことで この業を理解する場合も
皆様があの古い人々は大体現金主義で主義でしょ
で これ時代的には古いかもしれませんだけど
いくらでも自己管理できますよ
旅館のお金 現金で払う場合は
やっぱりお金持っていくんですね
クレジットカードだったら別にカード出しちゃえばいいんだもん
それで銀行に金あるかないかもう知らんぷり
それもクレジットカード会社ももうもう 200 200 万とかね
いろいろまあ 上げてくれるんです
もうローンできる 額は
で 一旦便利なんですが
この便利なものを使うためには人間に頭がないと
だからさらに社会が変わっていくと
さらに我々の理性 自己管理
自分の責任を自分で保つという
ことはさらに必要になるんですよ
今まで日本の女性っていうのは
ほとんど旦那さんの収入で生活していたんですよ
だから時代が変わって
やっぱり独立しなくちゃいけないんだと
で 収入が足らない場合は
夫婦で仕事をするのはね
まあそれはもう当たり前のことですけど
なんか独立しなくちゃってことで
奥さんも何か仕事をもらったりして
すると時間がいろいろなくなったり
忙しくなったりするから
いろいろありますけど
この独立すると 同時に責任も入ってくるんです
旦那さんに文句言えなくなっちゃうんだ
あんたこれやってない
あれやってないと じゃあ私は 1ヶ月半くらいどこかにちょっと遊びに行きますよって言ったら
そんなことしたら困ります
言えなくなっちゃいます
だって お互い様 ほとんど自立しているでしょ
それだったら 自分でそれなりの責任を持つ羽目になるんです
楽じゃないんです 別に自由になるのは悪くはないんですよ
頭が良ければ 問題はもうそれなんですね
もうロボット人生で 何でもかんでも自由に物事はできちゃうんですね
これがとても危険ですよ
えーと データ読みますから
はい 生まれ 生まれる時
結果としてのは業を相続するんです
だから生まれるとクレジットカードみたいなものを持ってくれればありがたいんだけど
現金みたいなものを持ってくるんですよ
小から死まで 生まれから死くまで業の管理下なんです
一旦 生まれるっていうことは
何かの業の結果なんです
その業が この人生まれた時から死ぬまでの面倒は見るんです
しかし 業は基本的な枠
型  OS です 業っていうのは私たちのあの人生の OS なんですよ
この人生の OS もこの WINDOWS と同じくガタガタなんです
決して 自分では何を悪いことしたっても壊れる
私のパソコンも壊れ 今壊れかけちゃって
私はプロがあの USB でいっぱい
この講演データあったんで全部消してるんで勝手に
だから私はただまあいつでも使うんだから
このさせたまんまでして
2日 3 日間もさせたままでいろいろ仕事をしたんですね
なんか嫌ね この赤いチャカチカチャカチカつって何やってんのかと思ったら
データ全部勝手に消してる
大量のデータなんですよ
OS のあり方があって
そんなもんなんです それからパーリ文字打つためにプログラムがありまして
これはインストールしてくれない
ものすごく固く断るんです
管理者には管理者なりの責任
ポリシーがあるんだろう
管理者は私ですけど それは何を探してもどこにもないんです MS
のホームページにだっても持ってない
そんなデータっていうのは
むちゃくちゃ自動的に
もうあの 今 WINDOWS7 出そうでしょ？だから VISTA が今壊れそう
それでまあそんな話はどうでもいいんですけど
あの これ真剣な話ですよ
私たちの人生にもある OS があるんです
OS だからあまり気づかないんですね WORD
使ったりとかね あのEXCEL 使ったりするんであって
このWORD を動かしているものっていうのは
そんなにも気にもしない
この C言語で書いてますけど
そんなのどうでもいいんです
私たちにとっては しかし
そちらに何かトラブっちゃうと
全て壊れてしまう 生まれてからの行為は
業という型の中で形成され
結果を出すんです そこで
なんで私はこの業は型だと言ったんでしょうかというと
我々は頑張って生きていかなくちゃいけないんですよ
だから 店からゲーム買ったり WORD
を買ったり いろいろそれが私たちは使っているものなんです
パソコンを買うと WINDOWS ついてるんです WINDOWS
入れないでパソコンは売らないんです
まあオタクは自分でね
もう部品買って組み立てるかもしれませんだけど
あの 私も一回やったことはありますけど
あの それでも何か OS いらなくちゃいけないでしょう
で 私たち買うパソコンっていうのは
もう全部もうプリインストールで
もう OS はインストールしています
それから何に使うのかとね
こちらの勝手で そのソフトは自分で買って使ったりする
しかし パソコンの中があまり良くないんだったら
OS が引っかかったりする場合は
もう結局は引っかかってしまいます
そういうことで私たちは頑張って生きてますよ
朝から晩まで仕事をするが
それほど収入はないとかね
いろいろ出ます あるいは苦労して苦労してお金を貯めて貯めておいたんだけど
突然なんかもう 何か起きちゃって
もう全部金がなくなってしまう
そういうのあるんですよ
で  20年ぐらいかけてローン払いますよでって計画立てて家を作っちゃったんですけど
ちょうど 5年でもう仕事はクビと
どうしますかね 今の状況ね
自分が悪いことをしてクビになったら
まあそれは自己責任ですけど
今の状況ではね まあ仕事終わると大会社だと
だからもうちゃんとローンはくれる
家を作るために で ローンを組んで家を作って
まあ一応五年ぐらいは払ったんですが
もうカチッと仕事がなくなったと
はい それからどうするのかと
せっかく自分は家やと思ったものは
もう安い値段で誰かに売り売ってしまう羽目になるんです
損ばっかりですよ その場合は
だからそういう人もいるし
もう例えば悪い時でも結構儲かる人もいる
だから我々は仕事をして生きている上で
このある OS があって
そこが管理するんですよ
だから 1 キロ走ったんだからといって
10人が10人も同じく疲れるわけじゃないんです 10
人一列に並んで はい スタートって言ったら 1 キロ走ると
1 キロの終了ゴールに来たら 10
人も同じレベルで疲れてる
息切れになっている人もいるし
全く平気でも もう息がまるっきり乱れていなくて
すごく普通にいる人もいるし
まあ 1 キロのところで倒れ込んじゃう
まあいやということでね
倒れ込む人もいるし  1 キロ走っている間でちょこちょこと休んだりする人もいるでしょう
そういうことで 同じ仕事をしてもどれぐらい収入を得られるのかという
どれぐらい幸福になるのかということの決まりは業がやっています
それが人生ということです
で 歌っている人っているでしょ
歌の才能があるかなく関係なく
人気者は別なんですね
本当にむちゃくちゃ儲かってすごく豊かな人もいるし
歌っても歌ってももうランチが食べられない人もいるんです
個人個人の実力でも 私はあんまりにも人気ある何人かの歌声を聞いて
なんでこの人はこんなに人気あるのかと
声はないし なんかこうやって結ばって
なんか歌ってるみたいと
楽器の音でも死んでるんですよ
しかし 無茶人気なんですよ
CD 出すと前もって予約しないともう買えないぐらい
それで他の人々の CD はざらーっと並んで誰も買わない
時々 CD をやっと出してくれて
それからもうどこかにもうなんか箱の上に乗って
街で歌わなくちゃいけない
それでも人は聞いてくれない
わかってくれないわけ
別に歌の能力とか訓練とか差がないんですよ
会社はもうものすごく厳しい訓練させて
まあそれぞれ考えて もう金もかかりますからね
もうデビューさせますよ
だからヒットするか ないかとかね
やっぱりその人の業になるんです
で 昔からもうちょこちょこでタイトルだけ紅白見るんですけど
私は日本に来てからも
何人かの人々が毎年紅白に出るんですよ
しかし 毎年同じ歌なんです
で  20年間も同じ歌を歌って紅白に出る
なんだこれと その年で頑張った人々から選ぶべきでしょうに
あれはもう確定席ですね
何三郎さんとかね なんとかなんとかとか
でもう一人女性のあの派手な女性のいるでしょ
別に歌も別に まああの芸能人としては才能ありますけど
歌は別に しかし確定席もう変わらないという
しかし 若者っていうのはもう紅白に出たということだけでどれほど喜んじゃうでしょう
じゃあこの差は不正？理不尽？どう説明するんですか？どうにもならないです
そんなの そういう人々のOSですよ
全然もう 5年も歌一つも出さなくても紅白に出られる人もいて
本当にすごい面白い歌を歌っているのに選ばれない人もいる
そういうことで 人生というものがいろんな人々を歌ってますけど
人生をね 大変もあったり
苦しみもあったり いいこともあったりとかね
あれやこれやとかね 別に仏教は人生を歌い歌いませんだからね
詩なんか歌いますけど
人生は歌いません 仏教の歌の題材になりません
これがガタガタで いろんなギザギザで
で ですよ これがこの我々は業という OS の上で生きているんです
それからあの なんで職業の講演に業が入りますかということは
まあ頑張って聞いていると
最後になんとなくわかるでしょうね
業の否定は邪見です ん？ 邪見の見が
見も危険な剣になりました
だからそれもこの一番変換は最高やという
この 2万円もかかったんですよ
あの英徳の 2007  2008なんとかというのを買って入れたんです
それはそちらの変換です
まあでも危険という邪見もいいです
無知な人は業を否定するんです
代わりに貪瞋痴の衝動で生きるんです
あの仏教 あのヒンドゥー教もなんとか業の話を言うんだけど
あれはもうろくな業じゃないんです
もうどうでもいい もうくだらん話で
業は本当にしっかりと語ってるのは仏教なんです
で 業っていうのは大体の大乗にあって
ヒンドゥー教に盗まれてヒンドゥー教にもありますけど
しかし ジャイナ教の業論っていうのはね
もう当てにならんで お釈迦様がやっぱりもう切っちゃったんですけどね
ヒンドゥー教には業はなかったんです
だからお釈迦様の批判はないんです
で 後で盗まれちゃったんです
仏教から しかし 仏教ほどわかってないんです
それで世の中 ほとんどの人々は業は認めませんね
無知で生きている これ
何でも神が決めるというね
あれっていうのはもう断然的な無知なんですよ
だって言った時点で屁理屈でしょうに
神はすごく平等で 生命をものすごく愛する者やと言いつつも
人間見たらね いい人に限って不幸で
だらしない恐ろしい人がすごい豊かで
それで話を聞いたら まあ神様に恵まれてとなってるんだと平気で言ったりしてて
だからそういう変なことを言った時点で
あれは業の否定なんです
人はどうなるのかって聞くのは神様やってことは
業は否定することでしょう
こういうのはとっても危険なんです
貪瞋痴は悪行です 悪業です
悪果になります だから業を否定する時点で生き方は悪業になるんです
我々の行いに結果があるんだよということを理解して生活しなきゃいけないんですよ
まあ何やってもいいやと思ったら
いくらでも悪いことするでしょう
だから優しく笑ったらそれなりの結果が来る
苦笑いしたらそれなりの結果が来るんだよと
嫌味で笑ったらそれなりの結果が来るんだよと
知った方がオートで自己管理なんです
で ゴミはポイ捨てするすべきかないかとかね
で なんでそんな看板書かなくちゃいけないんですか？失礼でしょうに
本当は ゴミはもうポイ捨てしないしないでくださいとか
あれやこれやとか いろんなところで看板書いてるでしょ
いかに人間が悪いっていう話でしょ
だから業は業だと 行為に結果あるんだと
知った時点でオートで自分の生き方を管理しているんです
悪いことしなくなるんです
その人は自ずから幸福になるんです
もう誰にも倒せなくなっちゃう
だって何の悪いこともしてないんだから
だから こうなんかあるわけないでしょうに
これは仏様 神様 阿弥陀様
何様か分からん お化け様
あれやこれやと私にもいろいろやってくれるんだと思う
思うと それが邪見です
誰も何もやってくれませんよ OS
で全部決めてるんです
いくら踏ん張ってもOSはもう超えられません
ですから この業を知った方がいいんです
恵まれた性豪であっても
何一つうまくいかない不幸な人生になるんです
業を否定すると 恵まれて生まれても
それからダメです いくらでも世の中を見てください
結構豊かな家族でかなり恵まれて生まれるんだけど
どうですか？最後に逮捕されますね
で 麻薬取ったり いろいろなことをやったりして
かなり人気のあるタレントの方々も逮捕されたりしたでしょうに
それからもう公に出られなくなっちゃうんですよ
業ぐらい知っておけば
そういうことにならないんですね
理性に基づいて不貪不瞋不痴の内で正語の行為をする
なんか間違ってる そう
生殖素晴らしい  何か間違いですけどね
あ 生後 生まれてからの行為ですね
はいはい 短くしようと思ってわからなくなっちゃった
あの 布団不自由ふちで生きてみるということは
生まれてから生まれが不幸であっても
すごく豊かになります
幸福に生きていられます
だから私の生まれが悪い
私の生まれが悪いとか泣く必要もないんです
これは何とかできます
はい それであの 後の話は一応終わります
なんでそんなこと言ったのかと
で 覚えておいてほしいんです
世の中でいろいろ仕事あります
1時間でも 10 万単位で収入を得るとか
1 時間仕事をすると 100万円とか
あの何秒かのコマーシャルに出る
あれ 昔の昔というか あのロッカシューがね
あのジャックセンというね
多く単位ですけどね で
これで日本はこの間の英語の冊子を読んだところで
で 元大統領っていうのは
アメリカでは大統領よりは儲かりますよと
みんな大統領になりたがっているのは
元大統領のというタイトルが欲しいんだと
エクスプレジデントというタイトルが欲しいんだと
どういうこと？ ひとつ例
あのレーガンさんという人がいてね
大統領になる資格があった人ではないんです
で で 終わってから日本に呼ばれて 20 分喋りましたと
20 分に彼にはえっと
6,000 万でしたっけ
払いましたと それでまだグループが来るんだから
そのグループにもまたえっと
8,000 万 8,000 かかったりして
多く飛んだんですよ  20 分の講演 20
分 また だってあの人 10 分喋ったっても大したもんですから
もう喋れませんだからね
何も知らないし 別に 私は思ったら
私は何 10 分喋ってますかね
まあ内容があるのに これは一生持っていたっても役に立つ内容でしょうね
大統領方々の話とは違うでしょうに
私の話をちゃんと理解すれば
もう死後も幸福になるでしょうに
地獄に落ちるんでしょうに
しかし収入は 0 だからこの
それは冗談で言いましたけど
あの 我々はそこは誤解しないでほしいんですよ
レーガンが 20 分で 6,000 万もらったんだからといって
世界人類を誰でも 10 分喋ったらそのお金もらうわけじゃないんです
レーガンの OS なんですよ
レーガンでしょうし 映画俳優でしょうし
その上 一番かっこ悪い
どうでもいいくだらん映画の俳優でしょ
それが人気あるんだからね
地味な映画にとっては全然誰も見てくれませんだからね
だから全部揃っちゃったんですよ
その上 大統領になっちゃったんだから
だから彼の OS はそういう風に動くんですよ
どんなくだらんことをやったっても
結構受けると だからあの業という OS で生きているんだということをわかれば
こんなゴチャゴチャ悩むことはなくなりますよ
適職って何ですかね？適職と業は残念ながら関係ありません
だから OS で決まってるんだったら
どんな仕事がいいかどうかね
自分の過去の業が知ってる人が教えてくれるのはありがたいでしょ
で 繰り返すことで心に傾向性癖が付くのです
腕が上がるのです 繰り返すのです
何かを 支配者は心なので
生まれる人の心にその能力が記録されているのです
これが業じゃないんです
何か繰り返して繰り返して繰り返してやっちゃうと
ちょっと脳の腕がね 脳で心の腕が上がるんです
それは心に記録されるんです
あの自転車に乗れることと同じですよ
一旦乗れるようになったらもう記録しているんです
業と関係ないんです 生まれてから
小五と書いているのは
この生まれてからって意味なんですね
慣れていた行為をするチャンスがあれば
見事に才能を発揮するんです
例えば 過去世でそうやって何か変な癖がついちゃって
生まれてからも何か似たものをできるようになっちゃったと
そういう仕事にする これがもうすごい才能ある
才能あるで言っちゃうんです
慣れてしまっていたんだから
今世でも何のことなくできるようになっちゃう
だから皆様に経験あると思いますけど
いろいろ人々を観察すると
もう何のことなくいろんなことできるようになったりしている
それは心にあの癖がね
傾向性がついているということなんです
しかし それわからないんですね
業も過去の才能もわからないから
超能力者に伺いたい気持ちはあるでしょうね
だから自分でご自分でわからないでしょ
業があるかもわからないし
過去で私はどんなことに慣れていたんでしょうかとか
わからないでしょ だったら一番手っ取り早いのは超能力者に聞いてみる
だから 汝は過去世でこういうこういう業を行って
こういうこういう職業をやったんだから
今世もこういうことをやってくださいと
この 2つはわからないものなので
アクションに聞くしかないんです
このわからないということは
アクション以外わからないということなんです
で 詐欺師なら何でも言いますから
もう日本ではいくらでもいますよ
そういう過去の業を教えてくれる人々は
だから一つ日本の文化ですから
騙されるのは 日本に長くいるとそれが悪いんです
全部見えちゃうんです
皆様が言っている文化と違う文化を私に見えるんです
騙されるという文化があるんですね
だからオレオレなんて振り込め詐欺やらね
いとも簡単です そういうのは考えるのも全く教育を受けて馬鹿な連中ですよ
よく考えて見事に多く単利で取ると
だから一つ消えていくと新しい何か現れてくる
みんな乗っちゃうんです
それでそれに騙されて騙されて
嫌やこれはとか法律で知るというと
そこはやめて別なことに騙されたんです
ですから 占い師に超能力者に聞くのは私は決して反対ではないんだけど
私に言えるのは そういうことを知りたければブッダに聞くしかないんです
ブッダが一応知っています
しかし そんなどうでもいいくだらないことをお釈迦様は教えません
で あの悟りに するために瞑想する場合は
ちょっとお釈迦様が調べてみて
あのね あんたこれじゃなくてこうやってやりなさいと言うんです
今日は修行修行したいんだと言ったら
お釈迦様が今日ではなくて
まあ今度の安護でいいんじゃないんですか？と言われたら
今度の安護なんです 今年ではないんです
それがこの過去を見ておっしゃっているんです
一番早く結果出せるのは
ものすごい少ない労苦労
だからこれが仏典でも
このブッダにしか他誰にもついてない能力だそうです
これプッガラパロパリアッティニャーナというんです
お釈迦様が特別な智慧いくつかあったんです
それが正覚者にしかつかないんです
いくら阿羅漢になっても
過去生を見える能力があったとしても
かなり推測して判断することになるんです
例えば 昔瞑想したお坊様方には
それなりに過去生を見える能力はあったんです
しかし 目連尊者さえも過去の物語をもって説法したことはないんです
この瞑想の達人は目連尊者というんです
あの方さえも あなたは過去でこうなったんだと言ったことはないんです
こんな立ち触りもしないブッダの境地だから
あなたは過去でもそんな馬鹿なことをやったでしょうというのは
お釈迦様ないです だからいかに大変難しいかということなんです
これはお釈迦様はなぜ難しいかと言うんですよ
例えば ある人の過去生を見たりする
現世でもいいんだけど
この人の生き方を見て死ぬ
死んだらどこに生まれたかを見る
見たら生きていた時は本当にいい加減に生きていて
全然善悪って全く無関心ですごい勝手に生きていて
死んだからいいところに生まれ変わっていると
だからそこは判断できないんだと
普通は それで誤解するんだと
あ なるほど いいことをしてても悪いことしたと同じことやと
生まれ死亡はいいところに生まれますよと判断するんだけど
そうではありません 我々大雑把で見れば
この人は悪人で悪いことしか何もやってないんだと言ったっても
業っていうのはこの小さな単位ですからね
その死を迎えてくると
誰も知らないうちに何かよくしたことがあるんですよ
だから善行為っていうのは
派手な善行為はそれほど力がないんですよ
例えば心でああ 私は悪いことをしましたから
今までね 何もできない状態で
これから心でも清らかに持ちましょうと
見えないでしょうに 誰にも
心には微塵も怒り入らない
欲が入らないように 嫉妬が入らないように
いうことをやると心はきれいだから
そのそのということは誰にも見えませんね
だから人を殺して刑務所に入れて死刑になった人でも
ああ あの人は地獄やと
これはわかりませんよ
もしその人は私は人を殺してなんて馬鹿なことをしたんですか
これくらい綺麗なことをする
一生懸命誰にも見えませんよ
しっかり心を持ったら知ったものじゃない
そうするとその結果は出ます
だからうかつに判断できませんよ
本物の超能力があっても
あの瞑想で過去を見る能力身についても
人の証しを見られる能力身についても
業の話は難しいんです
結論は難しいんです だから言う場合は推測しなくちゃいけない
こうだからこうじゃないのとかね
推測だから当たり外れ
はい それが人間の称号という生まれる業は
それが善業なんです 皆さんは知りたいですよ
私一人一人がどんな業で生まれたんでしょうかという
皆様方は善業で生まれたんです
それでちょっと調子に乗ったってば
人間ならみんなそうなんです
悪業で生まれません 人間が
あの天国に生まれるよりは難しいんですよ
人間に生まれることは
だから一番無駄使いした方がいいですよ
この短い人生を もうせいぜいちょっと 60年
80年ぐらいですから
これはやりたい放題無駄に使うんです
なぜならば もう稀の稀
人間に生まれるということは
滅多にできない だから人間に生まれるという業がものすごいパワフルで
ものすごい戦後なんです
ものすごいものが 無知のせいで自分で墓穴を掘ってるんです
しかし 人類を見てみると
ものすごい苦しんでいるでしょう
飢えているわ 病気でもう薬もなく死んでしまうわ
もうもう動物より動物以下のもう生活しているわ
殺すは殺されるわ 盗むは盗まれるわ
戦争を起こすわ 胸張って戦争に行くんですけど
この軍人たちはあのあれって人生ですから
どれほど苦しいかと だからはっきり言えば
お釈迦様はブッダにもなったのは人間だからなんですよ
だから人間になるためには聖母がこんなに力強くないとダメなんです
他のところに生まれたらもうブッダになれないんです
聖母の力がないんです
だからもう人間になったことっていうのは
もうとてつもないこと
大変な業があるんです
善行が だから人間頑張るならば
どこまで幸福になれるかということは知ったものじゃないんです
ちょっと整理整頓して頑張ってみると
どこまで幸福になれるか
知りようもないぐらいできます
天国に生まれるのはそんな簡単なことで
どうってことはないんです
いかに惨めかというと
神々におねだりするわ
お祈りするわ もうもう恐れ多く
法則も弱ですけど 生きるために欠かせないものが死までついてくるプログラムで生まれたことを理解して
まず自信を持つことです
だからそのために言ったんです
この業の話は まず自信を持ちましょうと
ちょっと雨が降っただけで
ちょっとアメリカのなんとかなんとかなっただけで
それでクタクタ倒れるっていうのは
これは愚か者たちがもう一緒にもう道連れに死んだのは構いませんだけど
で 一人一人がしっかり自信を持って
波風にも動揺しないように生活しなきゃいけないんです
だから あの 一人一人はすごいパワフルな前後があって
そこで生まれさせてるんです
こちらに送られてるんです
かなりの かなりの重い
あの財布と一緒に大量にあるんです
人間に生まれた時 持ってきた財布の中の幸福の財産が
これ穴だらけだからね
こちらで生活するともうやりたい放題
だからこれみんな無知だからそうなるんでするんであって
だからお釈迦様がそこら辺ただ教えているんです
それもうあちこち貪瞋痴で穴を開けるんじゃないの
感情で穴開けるんで穴開けたら全部漏れてしまいます
そうするともうどうしようもないんです
だから人間不幸になって
世界は不幸なのは一人一人のせいなんです
ん？ マイクをお願いいたします
マイクでマイクでお願いいたします
誰もがこれ持ってこてもらわないと手が痛くなるんです
あ そういうことですか
話やめてくださいっていう思ったんです
はい 将来の不安悩みが悪行為になる恐れがあります
それからよくやることでしょう
これでいいのか 将来どうなるのかとかね
あれ無駄ですよ 死ぬまで大丈夫です
死ぬまで生きていられますということなんですけど
で 例えば まあ結構豊かで余裕があって生きた人は死ぬまでそれで生きていられます
だから必要なのは自己管理なんです
この自分の号という財布に穴を開けないことなんです
だから我々は別にあまり問題ないにも関わらず
将来どうしようか 貿易になったらどうしようか
寝たきりになったらどうしようか
もうね もう痴呆になったらどうしようかと
癌になったらどうしようかとか
必ずそういうふうになるんでしょ
だから自分ですよ ボケそうっていうのは
だから仏教ははっきり言って
今日は明るく 楽しく 美しく
清らかな心で生きてみる
それで話は終了と その単純なポイントで
完璧な幸福になる方法を教えているんです
だからブッダの言葉はもう厳密にもうもう神の言葉じゃないんです
それはもう もう宇宙法則なんです
もう変わらないんです
そのまま実行してみれば
だから神 神にもブッダが教えるんだから
ブッダが神々の師匠でしょうに
人間だけじゃない だからこういうややこしい話はお釈迦様は実際な今ここで
って一言葉でまとめて見せるんです
だから いかに我々は無駄なことをやっているのかと
過去のことで悩んだりして
あれは失敗しました これは失敗しました
あの事業は失敗しましたとか
これで穴を掘るわ掘るわ掘るわ
自分のもう墓穴を 掘りすぎ
もう 1メートルもいらんでしょうに
これは 100メートルぐらい掘ってますから
どうしても掘りたければね
まあ 1 メートルはあんまり深すぎだから
200センチぐらいあればね
落ちたってまた上がる
たまたま落ちてもまた上がれるでしょうに
これがもう 1,000メートルぐらい掘ってるんだから
それでも足らなくて また掘る
地獄まで だから人間でありながら
もう地獄の楽しみを味わっているんです
だから余計なことをしないで
今だけ十分に今もう美しく心輝いて清らかな心でいてみる
笑って はい はい これであの一つのテーマ終わりました
何でしたっけ？今はあの
え？敵色 敵色